did you ever wonder what would happen if
tantaro met a different hashira during
episode 1 would any of the pillars spare
the siblings or were they just
mercilessly eliminate them also would
this lead to Tundra learning other
breathing Styles in this video we'll
cover Tundra's interaction with each
hashira and explain exactly what would
happen starting with sanami the wind
pillar first of all it's important to
note that Sunami is way more ruthless
than GI as we've seen during episode 22
when he cut nezuko and baited her with
his blood another important thing is his
tragic past in which a demon killed his
whole family leaving only him and his
brother alive due to these factors it's
really unlikely that he would want to
hear Tantra out Sunami is a firm
believer in the fact that humans and
demons can never co-exist therefore even
if nezuku tries to protect tandro he
wouldn't care and would ultimately kill
her with no mercy after this tanjaro
would be broken as not only did he lose
his entire family that night but also
nezuko there isn't really a reason for
sanami to kill Tantra in this situation
so he would probably just leave calling
him a weakling this time around although
Tantra survived he wouldn't have anyone
to train him and teach him about demon
Slayers therefore filled with rage he
would embark on his own journey to find
the people responsible for the death of
his family with no Demon Slayer training
whatsoever the only abilities Tundra
could rely on would be his sense of
smell and his inhumanly strong headbutt
and I don't think those would get him
very far he may be able to kill a couple
of weaker Demons by exposing them to
sunlight but in the end he would
eventually get killed by demons without
achieving anything okay that scenario
was pretty sad but what about tundra
meeting mitsuri would that turn out any
better well for starters mitsuri is one
of the kindest people in the Demon
Slayer core which also makes a lot of
sense with her being the love hashira
however don't underestimate her
capabilities because underneath this shy
and innocent character itsuri is a
strong and ruthless Demon Slayer who
takes her Ashira duties very seriously
with all this in mind if she was the one
who found entender instead of guiyu
things would take a really interesting
turn the important thing to remember
here is that Missouri was one of the few
people who accepted nezuko and even
treated her with love and care later on
therefore if she saw nezuko's
determination to keep her brother safe
it's unlikely that she would have the
heart to kill her so after learning
tanjaro's story she would sympathize
with him and offer to teach him about
demon slaying she also offers to teach
everyone watching this video how to hit
the Subscribe button and she'll be
really sad if you don't try it anyway
tanjaro's Journey with the love hashira
would be a sight to behold as instead of
water breathing he would get to learn
the love breathing technique but there
is actually a big problem with this you
see Matsuri was actually when Goku's
student when she first joined the corps
and her primary breathing style was
flame breathing however she quickly
realized that this style doesn't suit
her well so she created her own love
breathing this breath style is very
unique using a whip-like sword instead
of a normal one and relying mostly on
the user's flexibility and speed instead
of physical strength you can probably
see why this would be a problem for
tanjaro as flexibility isn't really his
main strength with this style he would
be much weaker compared to the original
story it would probably die early on in
the series even if he manages to survive
long enough to awaken Sun breathing he
would have a really hard time using it
properly this is because Sun breathing
requires the user to be physically
strong and since Tandra was practicing
love breathing this whole time he
wouldn't be strong enough to use it to
his full potential so regardless of what
breathing style he ends up using I don't
see Tantra surviving very long in this
scenario these scenarios so far were
pretty interesting but there are still
six different hashiras to cover and some
of these interactions you are definitely
not expecting open eye is the serpent
Tashira and is certainly among the most
merciless members of the Demon Slayer
core the guy is incredibly strict and
unforgiving even going as far as to tell
tenjin that he should have fought to the
death against utero and Doki criticizing
him for getting wounded against the
weakest upper Moon keeping this in mind
if he was the one to find Tantra in
episode 1 things would have gone very
very badly being the merciless guy he is
open I wouldn't even bother to take a
second to listen to tanjaro's please
moreover he would quickly end nezuko's
life leaving the boy traumatized and
alone with no one to rely on if by any
chance Tantra tries to protect his
sister by standing in front of her it
would also end tragically as open eye
would simply not care and slice both of
them in a second even if tantro does
survive the encounter without someone
like yorokudaki to teach him the ways of
demon slaying he would be completely
lost same as in the part where he met
sunumi he would probably try to find a
demon who killed his family and
somewhere along the way he would be
easily killed by demons up next is
shinobu the insect Tashira and tantro's
interaction with her would be a bit
complicated you see initially shinoba's
character in the show is displayed as
very cheerful and friendly showing her
as the kind of person who wishes to
coexist with the demons but as we know
that's not really the case she holds
immense hatred in her heart for demons
due to the fact that she lost so many
loved ones to them so does this mean she
would kill nezuko if she met this
siblings in episode one well although
we'll never know for sure I think there
is actually a big chance that both
nezuko and Tundra will survive this
encounter she would probably attack them
at first just as guiyu did but after
witnessing a demon nezuko protecting her
brother she would be stunned this would
most likely remind her of her own sister
Canal who lost her life to Demons she
would be curious as to why nezuku
behaves this way and would spare the
siblings from here on after learning
their full story she would accept tantro
as her sugoku and to train him to use
insect breathing technique however once
again there is a big problem with this
same as with Missouri's breathing style
and sex breathing is a technique
specifically made for shinobu's lack of
physical strength and it would be very
difficult for Tantra to use it properly
he would also have to learn about many
different types of poison and wield a
unique needle-like Katana it's
undeniable that insect breathing is one
of the worst choices for Tantra and
would eventually lead him being much
weaker than in the original story
properly mastering this technique would
take years and even if he does us Master
it I just don't see him surviving that
long therefore he would probably die
while engaging some of the stronger
demons like rui or guitero four more
scenarios are left and the next one is
everyone's new favorite hashira from the
sworn Smith Village muichiro tokito
yurichiro is one of those characters who
just don't care about anything happening
around them and are always stuck in
their own thoughts he also shows no
emotions whatsoever and acts on pure
logical reasoning although being logical
Is Not a Bad Thing by any means when it
comes to meeting tanj Ro and his demon
turned sister in the woods it's a really
bad thing for some hashira in this video
it's really hard to say what they would
actually do in this situation but when
it comes to morichiro there is no doubt
in my mind that he would instantly kill
nazuko maybe even tandro if he tries to
intervene uichiro's view on this is
simple nezuko equals demon demon equals
evil and as a hashira he needs to get
rid of evil boom done see you later okay
that encounter was pretty quick and
weird but what would happen if rengoku
was the one to meet the siblings on that
day would he do his hashira duty when he
spared them on the one hand rengoku is a
well-disciplined hashira and strictly
follows his duties however on the other
hand he has good intentions and a pure
heart as well as the mindset that the
strong should always protect the weak
based on this if tantro and nezuko are
able to get his attention and make him
listen I believe rengoku would
understand and empathize with them also
it's kinda hard to imagine rengoku just
mercilessly slicing them it's just not
what he would do anyway in this scenario
rengoku would teach tantaro flame
breathing and contrary to the other
styles we've covered so far this one
would actually suit him pretty well
Tundra is a natural wielder of the sun
breathing technique and the flame one is
really similar to it I'll even go as far
as to say that this breathing style
would probably suit him even better than
water breathing did in the original
version so what would happen to Tundra
after this well his journey would be
pretty similar to the original with him
going on some low ranked missions and
eventually facing rui at Mount natsugumo
at this point in the anime tanjaro
wasn't strong enough to defeat the demon
and was almost killed multiple times
however since he is stronger now I
believe he would manage to defeat rui
all by himself without even relying on
his Sun breathing abilities from here on
tanjaro would keep getting stronger and
stronger with each Arc and the story
would eventually end similarly to the
original with the core defeating muzon
before we cover what would happen if
Tundra met the strongest Tashira in the
current generation let's first quickly
go over his meeting with tenjen tenjin
is the sound hashira of the Demon Slayer
Corps and during the Entertainment
District Arc we learned that he cares
about people a lot and always puts
himself In Harm's Way to protect others
however when it comes to Demons he is a
completely different person and shows no
mercy whatsoever so although we all grew
to like tenjin during the last season
it's really hard to imagine him sparing
nezuko he is not as optimistic as
rengoku or as sensitive as gyome and
therefore he would most likely kill
nezuko quickly without thinking too much
about it and finally it's time for
tanjaro to meet yomei the strongest
hashira in the series and the wielder of
the stone breathing technique due to
kyoma's religion his upbringing he has
great love in his heart for all living
creatures and easily cries even over
minor stuff although the sibling would
definitely be scared when they see him
in the woods I think this interaction
would actually go pretty well for them
yomey is a really understanding person
and he would be able to sense that
nezuko's intentions are pure and genuine
and would therefore have no reason to
attack them after hearing tantaro out he
would take him under his wing and teach
him the stone breathing technique with
gyome as his trainer Tundra would
primarily focus on getting physically
strong as the stone breathing greatly
relies on that similarly to Flame
breathing Tantra would be much stronger
with this new style than he ever was
using water breathing The increased
physical strength would also allow him
to use Sun breathing more efficiently
later on in the story another change
that could happen in this version is
tantro using a different weapon to fight
possibly an ax or mace since those are
the weapons Kiyomi prefers regardless of
which weapon he chooses to use I believe
Tundra would be able to get insanely
strong using this breathing style and
things would probably go the same as in
the original did you ever wonder if all
demon moons together can defeat muzon
click on this video to find out the
answer may surprise you